d'abord un ministre qui paye cher son
bronzage hivernale fabien becker
des vacances à ibiza qui passe mal en
pleine crise du variant omicron prise à
partie par les députés cet après midi
jean michel blanquer air se défend la
symbolique je la regrette mais pour le
reste madame la députée depuis deux ans
avec la majorité avec mes équipes avec
tous les professeurs de france nous
tenons la politique de l'école ouverte
c'est cela qui est l'essentiel et nous
nous perdons pas dans l'accessoire comme
l'a révélé mediapart le ministre se
trouvait à ibiza quand il a annoncé le
nouveau protocole sanitaire dans les
écoles début janvier un protocole
dévoilé à la dernière minute la veille
de la rentrée dans une interview au
parisien d'abord accessible aux seuls
abonnés en ligne du journal cette
communication tardive avait créé le
désarroi parmi les directeurs
d'établissement alors depuis les
révélations sur les vacances de jean
michel blanquer la critique est unanime
cette désinvolture qui consiste à à
partir
passer ses vacances dans des endroits un
10 paradisiaque
démontre d'abord une forme de désintérêt
pour ce que vivent les français en
pleine campagne présidentielle plusieurs
voix à gauche appellent à la démission
du ministre
au sénat les oppositions préfère s'en
prendre à son bilan en vue de l'élection
présidentielle
un ministre a le droit de prendre des
congés il a le droit même de partir à
l'étranger si nan prévient son son
patron à savoir le premier ministre mais
très honnêtement c'est une très très
grosse maladresse ça vient aggraver le
bilan négatif que je considère ii du
quinquennat macron est ce qu'on doit
reproché à jean luc blanc caire c'est
d'abord la pagaille et pas tellement le
lieu d'où il annonce que telle ou telle
mesure et puis surtout surtout surtout
c'est le bilan longtemps considéré comme
le bon élève du gouvernement jean michel
blanquer air se voit aujourd'hui plus
fragilisée que jamais après une grève
très suivie le 13 janvier les syndicats
appellent à une nouvelle journée de
mobilisation jeudi 20 janvier et on en
débat tout de suite je vous présente mes
invités françois patriat bourg soir un
soir bienvenue vous êtes sénateur la
république en marge de la côte-d'or
président du groupe rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes indépendant au
sénat bruno cautrès bonsoir politologue
direct et chercheur au cnrs et au
cevipof bienvenue à vous jean sébastien
ferjou bonsoir jean sébastien vous êtes
le fondateur le directeur de la
publication du site atlantico laetitia
cru pas éditorialiste politique bonsoir
laetitia bienvenue à avoue aussi bon je
ne résiste pas je vais commencer par
citer ce bon mot cette bonne vanne de
françois-xavier bourmaud qui est grand
reporter au service politique du figaro
c'est sur twitter et il nous dit les
emmerdes ça vole en espadrilles
franchement c'est très bien trouvée
référence à la citation de jacques
chirac évidemment les emmerdes ça vole
toujours en escadrille c'est vrai quand
même françois patriat on va redevenir
sérieux que les difficultés en devenir
poli s'accumulent pour le ministre de
l'éducation alors non ce que je viens de
voir j'ai pas trouvé grandes personnes
pour soutenir le ministre je n'ai vu que
une série d'effets il aide le genre en
vue patrick kanner à l'instant était
lui-même ministre peut-être qu'ils en
profitent pour parler du bilan des piles
un mois génère qu'on compare les bilans
mais le bilan aujourd'hui de monsieur
blanc caire c'est quoi 6 milliards pour
l'école en plus l'école obligatoire à 3
ans le dédoublement des classes dépens
de la côte est il rencontre des
meilleurs salaires pour les salles pour
les pour les enseignants est ce
qu'aujourd'hui il ya un ministre avant
monsieur blanc qu'elle peut avoir un tel
qu'ils aient pu avoir un tel bilan et je
trouve que c'est bilan est bon et qui
sera à défendre donc non on parlera du
bilan suite des deux ans de contrat ni
terre parce que c'est aussi ça qui a
éventuellement mené
sur le sur le fait que c'est pas le bon
moment qu'il est en difficulté qu'il ya
une grève de des enseignants qui est
renouvelée de nouvel appel pour jenny
d'abord sur cette grève qui revient
aussi un instant les enseignants ont
fait grève la semaine dernière c'était
pas facile pour les parents non plus
enfin ils ont fait grève c'est légitime
ils l'ont fait ils ont obtenu
satisfaction quasiment sur tous les
points jeudi soir avec monsieur le
premier ministre il reprend une grève
sur les mêmes motifs aujourd'hui alors
prenez toujours en pleine crise
sanitaire je leur laisse la
responsabilité est ce que est ce que les
ministres comme une maladresse sans
doute il le reconnaît lui même moi j'ai
vu tout à l'heure un homme à l'assemblée
un homme qui était touché blessés
ennuyée bien entendu il l'a dit et il
l'a fait quand même une contrition pour
le veuille ou non en disant ça peut-être
je le regrette je n'aurais pas dû le
faire mais dans le même temps je veux
dire est ce que est ce que ça vous
demande de démission un tel acharnement
aujourd'hui c'est une difficulté
supplémentaire ça créera sans doute des
difficultés au gouvernement j'en
conviens aujourd'hui on peut se passer
de ce genre de défaite m mais enfin je
crois que il faut remettre cet événement
ce qui est une maladresse qui est
péripéties n'ont pas deux campagnes mais
de d'épisodes sanitaire aujourd'hui à sa
défense aussi ils pouvaient pas faire
autrement il a comme il l'a dit
travailler il a cohabité avec ses
ministres en permanence et les divisions
qui ont été prises elles ont été prises
au moment où il le pousse je vous
donnerai la part de plusieurs fois
évidemment d'andorre dans ce débat je
voudrais entendre mais mes autres
invités bruno cautrès blanquet ibiza ça
pourrait presque être le titre d'un
quatrième volet d'oss 117 vous voyez ce
que je veux dire ça sonne ça sonne
roulement quand même à nos oreilles oui
ça fait presque un oxymore à une
certaine manière parce que jean michel
blanquer a plutôt une image de quelqu'un
d'extrêmement sérieux c'est un grand
professionnel les questions de
l'éducation depuis de très nombreuses
très nombreuses années il a fait sa
carrière sur c'est sur ces questions et
il a une image plutôt de domme de
dossiers qui traînent beaucoup qui est
très sérieux donc effectivement il ya un
côté un peu paradoxal dans dans cette
affaire je pense qu'on veut pas
comprendre l'ampleur que ça prend s'il
n'y a pas tout le contexte autour c'est
à dire le sentiment un peu de désarroi
des profs des parents d'élèves des
élèves même face à la situation très
compliquée et jean michel blanquer est
pas responsable de tout
l'épidémie est le même et évolutive donc
il ya quand même un sentiment quand même
de confusion qui a fait beaucoup de
parents d'élèves on a entendu énormément
de témoignages dans les médias de
parents qui dit j'en ai marre j'en peux
plus je passe je mets semaine à tester
mes enfants et donc je pense qu'on peut
pas comprendre l'importance que ça a
pris en dehors de ce contexte cela et
j'imagine que même si jean-michel
blanquer avait été faire du ski de fond
en laponie et pas une bise à en ait pris
une telle importance ce très très fortes
comme ça a été le cas et peut-être un
peu moi jean sébastien ferjou il ya
quand même une
symbolique autour d'ibis hacker
peut-être d'ailleurs un peu ridicule je
ne sais pas ce que vous en pensez mais
il ya quand même ça
n est pas ridicule ou simplement lui à
l'hiver il vise à l'été c'est quand même
pas la même chose sauf que les soirées
avec des dj en plein air quand même
rarement armes en plein hiver rien me
dit de toute façon ibiza y aussi des tas
d'endroits à 16 sièges que si jean
michel blanquer y était allé l'été ça
aurait été pour aller dans une réelle et
c'est vrai que dans la gauche est en
cause et gaz de synthèse elle correspond
pas dans l'inconscient collectif das
côté bling-bling quoi il ya surtout le
décalage entre un sentiment d'urgence et
le fait que le ministre n'avait pas
l'air disponibles après c'est
effectivement un reproche qui est
finalement pas très intéressant il y en
a bien d'autres vous y en a une image
plutôt des questions à poser au
gouvernement plutôt que de savoir où
était monsieur bancaire au moment où il
annonce des mesures les mesures en
question surtout à l'art du télétravail
j'ai envie de vous dire ça encore plus
paradoxal dans la mesure où on demande à
tout le monde d'être en télétravail non
ce que je skie me surprend plus c'est le
peu de soutien de la majorité finalement
je vous entends là ce soir on a entendu
madame macron finalement se montrer
beaucoup plus en soutien de monsieur
blanc caire que la plupart des
parlementaires elle rêve le vrai sujet
enfin pardon jean-michel bancaire
l'avait lui-même mis sur la sur la table
c'était qui est responsable ce n'est pas
le ministère de l'éducation nationale
qui détermine les protocoles sanitaires
c'est le ministère de la santé qui avait
une interview dans le jdd le même
dimanche et si on comprend bien les
propos de jean-michel bancaires ont été
validés tardivement par matignon et par
le ministère de la santé peut-être
faudrait-il s'intéresser alors non pas
au lieu des vacances d'olivier véran
parce que ça ne s'en fiche éperdument en
revanche au fait qu incontestablement il
y avait quand même un cafouillage oui et
puis en détention des tensions entre les
deux mini jeux ventes exprimées avant le
conseil des ministres nommés tout à fait
mais je pense que ça se concentre avec
mike jean-michel bancaire parce que et
vous le disiez il des coréens des
muscats un bilan qui est vraiment
défendable après ce quinquennat et
notamment sur la pandémie l'objectif de
maintien des classes c'est une vraie
réussite bien celle en revanche la
gadoue démarrer de préféré entendre des
questions de l'opposition un peu plus
précise encore plus sérieuse sommes nous
sommes nous donner les moyens de cette
ambition là toujours sur les capteurs
sur co2 l'aération et d'autres assurent
les critiques de salivaires qui avait
été annoncé qu'ils n'ont jamais été mis
en oeuvre et c'est alors j'accueille
nicolas domenach qui est avec nous en
duplex en visioconférence éditorialiste
à challenges
et vous publiez tient avec maurice
szafran mâcon pourquoi tant de haine
chez albin michel on pourra peut-être
faire le lien avec le bilan du
quinquennat présidentiel bonsoir nicolas
domenach merci d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation je viens vers vous dans un
instant mais je voudrais donner la
parole à laetitia cru pas acquis qu'ils
voulaient
ah oui des gens c'est bien parce que en
fait quand on écoute la question de la
députée à jean michel blanquer
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée nationale elle
ne parle absolument pas 10 bis à elle
évacue tout de suite le problème du lieu
de veiller jatte ur du ministre elle lui
parle de sa légèreté dans sa gestion de
la crise sanitaire et du pose des
questions qui sont très précises
justement sur sa communication sur le
délai on le sait maintenant que le haut
conseil a envoyé ses conclusions le 31
au soir c'est à dire le vendredi surtout
qu'il a fait lui le samedi pour ajuster
et le dimanche la communication mais
c'est jean michel blanquer air qui
décide aujourd'hui de répondre sur ibiza
sans jamais dire ibis à ça vous l'aurez
remarqué évidemment dans sa défense de
répondre directement et de désamorcer la
polémique
or thomas ça s'est joué franchement à
quelques heures parce que vous avez tout
à fait raison le lieu ibisa n'aurait
posé aucun problème si juste le ministre
était rentré à temps pour répondre aux
partenaires sociaux si on prend un peu
si on reprend un peu le calendrier on va
là on va leur donner deux des
révélations autour de ce protocole
sanitaire à l'école effectivement
vendredi 31 décembre l'avis de la haute
autorité de santé dimanche 2 janvier
l'interview de jean-michel blanquer au
parisien lundi 3 l'entrée en vigueur du
protocole et puis une semaine après ces
gens cat s jean castex qui vient au 20
heures de france 2 finalement pour
proposer un nouveau protocole parce que
celui qui avait été proposée était
quasiment inapplicable ou est compliqué
comme vous dites c'est une litote
donc vous l'avez évoqué françois patriat
évidemment les candidats à la
présidentielle seront s'en donnent à
coeur joie depuis ce matin on va écouter
tient tout de suite yannick jadot
c'était sur france 2
tous demandent la démission de jean
michel blanquer vous savez je n'ai pas
l'habitude de demander la démission des
ministres parce que finalement la
responsabilité des politiques c'est le
président de la république il faut pas
renvoyer au ministre une responsabilité
qu'il n'ont pas mais là on a un problème
d'équations personnelle de la part du
ministre jean michel blanquer c'est à
dire que depuis des mois et des mois ils
méprisent la communauté éducative il
méprise les enseignants ils méprisent
les parents d'élèves et les élèves et le
niveau d'impréparation
d'improvisation permanente sur les
protocoles sanitaires à l'école
remettre en cause sa préparation son
sérieux
nicolas domenach faites vous partie de
ceux qui qui enfonce ou qu'ils défendent
plutôt jean michel blanquer
je trouve que je déteste et chasse à
l'homme d'une manière générale et en
particulier celle ci puisque comme il a
été rappelé on a quand même sur les cols
blancs un ministre qui a tenu l'école
ouverte contre d'ailleurs
l'administration contre une partie des
syndicats qui voulait affirmer contre
edouard philippe pendant un moment dire
et au fond aujourd'hui on s'en prend à
celui qui a réussi quelque chose c'est
quand même inouï alors je corps est
juste une petite chose puisque je suis
coincé par un kobe d'importuns j'en ai
pas j'ai passé une partie de la journée
a téléphoné de ci de là la majorité pour
une fois elle fait bloc elles de manière
étonnante même aussi bien les disait que
matignon les ministères vous ne
trouverez pas de voix discordantes dire
on soutient blanc caire parce qu'on se
rend bien compte qu'on soutient un bilan
le mental c'est empêche pas une faute de
communication tout ce que vous voulez
mais il paye et se terminera là dessus
il paye au pont on a parlé mais prix
hyper à mes prix qui était celui du
maquereau nisme des débuts et qui a
imprimé fortement et qui est la marque
jaune de l'arrogance est vraiment la
cdip cher mais vous dites la majorité
fait bloc pas beaucoup sur les plateaux
de télévision ou sur les ou sur les
radios quand même à et pour ceux patriat
vous êtes aujourd'hui vous avez fait le
choix aujourd'hui vous étiez pas traduit
j'en suis très fier oui le nicolas
domenach voyez ce que je veux dire bliss
mais pas forcément première trouvez-nous
des déclarations vous verrez en tout cas
moi tous les ministres que j'ai eus j'en
ai eu plusieurs au bout du fil qui en
général ne mâchent pas leurs mots et
bien au fond ils soutiennent ils
soutiennent blanca on est rentré dans un
combat politique maintenant il s'agit
plus de se tirer dans le dos il s'agit
de qu'un bloc ils ont enfin compris ça
les ti crs que jean michel blanquer a
fait une faute politique pour vous non
chez c'est d'accord pour tout le monde
le soutient déjà juste pour répondre à
nicolas pourquoi parce que tout le monde
était au courant donc bien sûr que tout
le monde est responsable je veux dire
jean michel blanquer repart pas ibis à
tout seul sans prévenir annie matignon
et l'elysée et on sait aussi que il est
protégé par brigitte macron qui l'a fait
rentrer à l'elysée donc voilà pourquoi
aussi on pense on préfère le protéger ce
plan là mais au plan politique ce n'est
pas une faute on l'a démontré au plan de
la communication politique évidemment
c'est une faute pourquoi parce que tout
simplement on ne peut pas quand on est
ministre ignorer les précédents les
précédents qui sont des cas d'école donc
et qui sont les cas d'école à ne pas
reproduire justement quand on est comme
ça en pleine crise quelle que soit la
nature de la crise là c'est une crise
sanitaire mais quelles que soient la
nature par exemple récemment elisabeth
bornes je vous rappelle ses on a déjà
oublié mais à noël période de noël 2019
grève des transports galère dans les
trains pour tous ceux qui surtout les
franciliens qui veulent se se rendre au
travail et puis aussi pour ceux qui
veulent partir en vacances et
la ministre des transports à l'époque
par à marrakech fêter noël très bien
c'est s'est permis par le gouvernement
ces deux heures c'est une règle tacite
on peut partir à deux heures on est
joignable on travaille et à son retour
évidemment a déclenché vraiment un flot
de critiques elle ne répond pas
personnellement on en voit qui on envoie
un pompier christophe castaner regarder
foot français qui prennent l'avion parce
que l'avion est disponible il ya pas mal
de français qui planent les trains parce
que des trains circulent dans notre pays
il ya pas mal de français qui prennent
quelques vacances aussi et je pense que
la ministre en charge de l'environnement
peut avoir quelques jours de vacances
pour considérer que c'est un sujet qui
appelle à la polémique moi je considère
que ce n'est pas le cas je pense même
que c'est nécessaire que chacun puisse
aussi se poser quelques temps et
retrouver son unité familiale c'est le
cas pour elisabeth bornes c'est cas pour
moi aussi c'est le cas pour chacune et
chacun d'entre nous je pense que la
polémique est bien inutile voilà moi ils
avaient sorti les rames christophe
castaner et puis ça l'efficacité que ça
mais finalement il ya surtout ce cas
d'école de 2003 c'était il ya 18 ans
enfin voilà un moment il va voir que
quand même on arrive à tirer des leçons
du passé jean françois mattei en pleine
canicule meurtrière on le sait on le
répète ans c'est tellement un cas
d'école que c'est devenu aussi une
séquence culte de la télévision il est
en polo il répond à tf1 il vous répond à
vous puisque c'est vous qui êtes aux
commandes du jt et il est dans son
jardin du var et il ya en totale
déconnexion vous souvenez certainement
de cette séquence mais oui ça c'est sûr
qu'il est il est en totale déconnexion
sur tout ce qui nous avait marqué à
l'époque c'était le décalage entre ce
que les reporter de la rédaction de tf1
nous faisait remonter du terrain ce que
les ce que les pompiers de paris ce que
les équipes du samu aussi nous disait
sur le la gravité du du bilan et c'est
ce sentiment qu'au delà du code
vestimentaire qui était effectivement
sans doute une belle adresse il y avait
un vrai décalage pour ne pas dire une
méconnaissance par le ministre de ce qui
était la réalité et la gravité de la
canicule à paris à l'époque donc c'est
surtout ça qui était qui était frappant
moi qui nous avait frappés on est
présent la configuration inverse son
calcul il est à dire que peut-être la
gravité et l moindre oui le gouvernement
est face à une contradiction politique
puisque pour faire voter le pass sans
fin il est désormais voter mais pour
assurer le vote du pass vaccinale il
faut en quelque sorte dramatiser la
situation je ne parle pas de la crise
depuis ses débuts je vous parle de la
période actuelle est la réalité qu'on
constate dans les écoles c'est que de
toute façon le coup est parti s'il y
avait eu quelque chose à faire pour
limiter la circulation virale c'était de
toute façon en amont qu'il fallait le
faire avec toujours la même chose de
contrôle aux frontières bref ça n'a pas
été fait et donc en quelque sorte on
voit bien que cette contradiction entre
d'un côté ballet ses filets parce que de
toute façon tout simplement on n'a plus
les moyens de faire grand chose et on
constate ce qu'on ne savait pas a priori
pas raccrocher au gouvernement de ne pas
savoir comment le virus va se développer
mais une moindre létalité de micron est
par ailleurs cette dramatisation pour
garantir le pass vaccination va bien
finalement il est plus construit sur une
logique politique sur le gepan quoi je
cite à jean françois mahé il pas pour
comparer de façon on se penchera
moulinet ne sais pas c'est la mission
pense que c'est pas comparable avec ce
que je veux dire que ce n est pas du
tout comparable mais je pense et j'en
suis sûr que c'est dans le manuel de la
de la com politique parfaite qui se
trouve sur tous les bureaux de tous les
ministres et c'est à dire que quand on
est en décalage quelle que soit la crise
avec l'opinion publique on ne part pas
dans un lieu qui peut choquer et qui
peut déclencher une polémique on est
capable normalement quand on est au
gouvernement
d'autant plus quand on a justement tiré
les leçons du passé d'appréhender l'état
de l'opinion publique c'est votre boulot
wen au 4s mais il me semble que là il un
échec françois guernon j'entends des
fêtes comparaison ne paraît pas juste
parce que au moment où me dit est en
difficulté il est en vacances et les
gens meurent les gens meurent et on ne
prend pas conscience de ce qui se passe
il ya des drames et il tombe parce que
parce que la crise est loin d'être finie
qu'elle n'ait pas perçu et qu'elle n'est
pas traitée alors que là aujourd'hui la
crise elle est perçue et les traiter il
ya des mesures sur le pass sanitaires
c'est vrai que la situation aujourd'hui
quand j'entends dire que c'est trop tard
le pass le pass vaccinale pardon je
rappelle qu'il ya dans la journée vingt
mille côte à 20 vingt mille personnes de
plus qui prend la picole 450 deux
enfants 452 aux enfants hospitalisés
287 morts on est dans des chiffres qui
sont comparables à ceux de l'année
précédente dans la situation est
dramatique est
aujourd'hui difficile le choix
d'instruments pire joie si la pandémie
sommet à l'autre alors le post
vaccinales il a deux vertus première
vertu c'est que malgré tout en empêchant
des gens non vaccinés d'aller partout
ils empêchent la circulation des virus
et deuxièmement il est fait il est là il
est là à de l'increvable mais n'est pas
moi quand même malgré tout mais et si
quelqu un porteur d'eau microdon
vacciner il a plus de chance de le
donner que quelqu'un qui soit vacciné
toi je continue à les aider et de
surcroît et il est là aussi pour forcer
les gens seront vaccinés on est bien
entendu c'est pour faire c'est pour ça
qu'il allait passer vaccinale et on veut
qui permet la prise au micro après la
crise et qui est la meilleure incitation
des pays qui n'ont eu ni obligation ni
passe ni sanitaires ni vaccinaux sont
atteints de meilleurs objectifs sur les
cibles fragile quand vous regardez à
l'heure actuelle les primo injection en
france quand vous regardez les troisième
dose regarder le classement des pays de
l'union européenne notamment vous verrez
que tous ceux qui sont devant la france
sont des pays qui ont choisi une méthode
différente où la confiance dans la
parole publique est plus grande mais
c'est un autre débat c'est à dire que le
classe vaccinale
pour les débats la risée linge mais un
élément devra jouer face à l'espagne
c'est le cas en histoire dont je
remarque c'est le cas je rajoute un
élément parce que ça va beaucoup plus
contraignant va dans votre sens je ne
sais pas si vous êtes d'accord avec ce
que dit marine le pen mais c'était
blindé
de sa démonstration a été dans une
conférence de presse générale ce matin
et elle a évoqué on a entendu tout à
l'heure dans dans le temps le sujet les
mots de désinvolture mais ça va plus
loin on écoute la candidate du
rassemblement national cette
désinvolture elle dit quelque chose
voyez cette désinvolture qui consiste à
à partir
passer ses vacances dans des endroits un
10 paradisiaque
démontre d'abord une forme de désintérêt
pour ce que vivent les français en
pleine campagne présidentielle et le
deuxième enseignement c'est qu'en
réalité on n'est pas confronté à une
crise sanitaire donc on est confronté
bien à
volonté politique c'est à dire que ce
qui justifie cette forme d'agitation de
la part du gouvernement en terme de
votes du pass notamment vaccinale et de
multiplication des protocoles n'est pas
une raison sanitaire car si c'était une
raisons sanitaires je suppose que
monsieur blanc caire ne serait pas sur
les plages d'ibiza les doigts de pied en
éventail si un ministre important est en
vacances à ibiza en pleine crise
sanitaire c'est qu'il n'y a pas vraiment
de crise sanitaire et que hausse au
monospace vaccinale c'est une agitation
ou un objet politique obama critique ce
serait vrai runes le pen ce serait vrai
si les mesures n'étaient pas prises ce
serait vrai si le ministre travaillait
pas ce serait vrai si le gouvernement ne
dit si t'es pas il faut se remettre à
l'instant comme un instant vous à vous
avez donné la chronologie un leur
rendez-vous sanitaire est donné le
vendredi soir les arbitrages ont lieu le
samedi 1er ce qui est plus consulté
l'elysée matignon vers en était le
samedi s'est rendu et en fin de compte
qui communique comme unique le samedi
soir ça paraît le jeudi ça n'aurait rien
changé que les gens chez les enseignants
les parents le dimanche de son le
sachent le vendredi parce que c'était
par contre là où je rejoins c'est que le
protocole qu'à imposer qu'on impose et
les autorités sanitaires est à prendre
le pr protocole impraticable difficile
mais il semble tout changer mais
difficile ce soit le vendredi est pas la
vraie âme et bien sûr le nom mais bon ça
va
sur un site
we know cotation n'avons pas entendu
quel que soit le calendrier la décision
c'est vrai que la déclaration de marine
le pen va sans doute porté dans le dans
l'opinion c'est ce type d'arguments très
sain bien sûr raccourci quai
si la crise gravissime pourquoi le
ministre étant est en vacances et c'est
vrai que l'on peut faire court je
retiens je vais dans le même sens que
les tice accrue pas tout à l'heure qui
est de dire au fond une toile de fond
dans l'opinion publique qui est que la
manière dont les français perçoivent les
responsables politiques c'est qu'ils
sont pas empathique c'est que ils vivent
dans une bulle humains petit peu à part
donc quand y'a pas de crise au fond
cette toile de fond elle est là et tout
le monde s'en accommode à peu près mais
c'est vrai que quand une situation de
crise la meilleure protection que les
hommes et femmes politiques doivent
s'appliquer c'est la fameuse théorie des
deux corps du roi il ya là il ya
l'individu ministre qui a envie qui a
besoin sans doute de passer du bon temps
d'être en vacances et puis à la fonction
et c'est vrai quand on est en situation
de crise et la fonction qui doit
l'emporter sur la personne il ya des
choses que l'opinion publique ne
supporte plus on le sent bien et
je reviens vers vous puisqu'on vous
étiez pas encore arrivé un jeu je vous
dis tout dit ou à nos téléspectateurs
au tout début quand on a parlé vraiment
de la symbolique ibiza est ce que ça
rejoint finalement ce côté bling bling
ce là l'une des principales critiques
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure qui colle
un peu aux basques des manuels macron le
président des riches
mais c'est le président des riches
étaient la marque du début du
quinquennat mais ça va au delà c'est à
dire début du quinquennat la suppression
de l'sf la hausse des apl et puis les
premiers de cordée dont on a pensé
qu'ils étaient par trop privilégié donc
ça c'était pour le président des riches
mais il ya eu aussi toutes les petites
phrases qui se sont
succédé et qui ont fait et qui ont
renforcé le président duo le président
qui regarde ceux d'en bas comme est un
vraiment très très bas et qui ont donné
ce sentiment du mépris dont on ressent
aujourd'hui les échos d'hier c'est ça
qu'on retrouve aujourd'hui même si c'est
corrigé grandement ils se surveillent
beaucoup mais n'empêche que ça a donné
lé début de quinquennat sont toujours
ceux qui donnent la marque de la suite
et çà et là ça ça c'est resté gravé et
au front on en trouve des échos mais
avec le colis dont demande aussi de
l'efficacité donc ce qu'on dit
aujourd'hui ne sera peut-être pas ce qui
vaudra dans trois semaines si dans trois
semaines dire tout d'un coup on est
sorti de la crise épidémique si les
écoles sont restées ouvertes en dépit
des erreurs démentent veut dire des
protocoles et dont je rappelle quand
même protocole qui sont décidés non pas
par le ministère de l'éducation mais
d'abord par matignon la santé puis
ensuite celui de l'émissaire de
l'éducation donne son point de vue mais
je veux dire c'est une décision
collective donc si l'efficacité est au
rendez vous alors tout ce qu'on dit
aujourd'hui n'aura ne pèsera pas grand
chose à mon avis bruno cautrès
c'est intéressant ce que dit le lien
avec le bilan du quinquennat du présent
et publics est finalement la symbolique
qui est attachée à tort ou à raison à
ses premiers mois qui moi je le redis un
clip beat colle un peu simple sparadrap
du coin c'est très clair moi je l'étudié
pas mal en profondeur en regardant
beaucoup une question ouverte qu'aux
postes dans des enquêtes de pions sur
l'image d'emmanuel macro et vous avez
une sorte de clivage qui s'est scellée
extrêmement tôt dans son dans son mandat
sans doute dès le premier tiers de son
mandat avec d'un côté une minorité de
français qui est son son coeur de cible
son fan club qui considèrent qu'il est
le héros d'une narration qui est il
essaye de réformer un pays impossible à
réformer et ils enjambent les obstacles
avec talent je me retrouve rien beaucoup
de chômeurs à j 1 et puis vous avez en
face vous avez en face effectivement une
france qui ne comprend pas emmanuel
macron qui a le sentiment qu'il est pas
raccord avec l'histoire du du pays qu'il
appartient à un autre univers
qui l'est pas il n'a pas les pieds sur
terre qu'il est arrogant qui peut pas
comprendre le peuple parce que son
histoire familiale son histoire
personnelle pardon qui est une histoire
de la d'une réussite être élus présents
république à l'âge de 39 ans si ce n'est
pas une réussite incroyable est donc
structurellement il peut pas comprendre
parce que il est depuis toujours dans le
domaine de la réussite et dans une
narration très positive et donc il ya
une sorte de queue relation complètement
stone ionale entre lui et le pays c'est
ce que ressent une partie devient france
il faut pas réagir et malgré le couac il
en coûte malgré la l'implication du
président la crise sanitaire on trouve
toujours effectivement nicolas domenach
a raison on trouve toujours des traces
extrêmement importante de ces petites
phrases et du début qui est quelqu'un de
d'arrogant et qui peut pas comprendre
structurellement le peuple sébastien et
intervenir oui c'est certain que ça se
pose exactement comme ça oui les
français ont un rapport particulier à la
réussite financière à l'égalité on ne
sait après je pense que jean marie le
pen notamment une situation financière
aisée vu dans un parc dans un hôtel
particulier ça n'a jamais dérangé les
gens il ya des tas d'exemples de
populiste a commencé par donald trump
qui va en vacances au soleil qui passe
son temps dans des lieux pour
milliardaires et servir angers peirsol
eric zemmour
avant de passer des vacances je pense
visé onéreuse pendant la coupure de la
marine appel faisait d'une pierre deux
coups en parlant de ceux qui se fichent
finalement le destin des français en
partant dans des lieux paradisiaques
puisque saint barth est trop long plus
paradisiaque au mois de décembre que
mener ibiza mais bref tout ça pour dire
que le problème c'est le décalage entre
l'offre politique que vous incarnez et
l'image c'est pas ton l'image elle-même
à mon avis regarder en bernard tapie il
assume et qu'il était il a assumé il le
disait lui-même jamais le
souvenir d'une de ses phrases jamais les
femmes de ménage dans les îles ou
demander des comptes sur le phocéa en
revanche les gens de la gauche caviar
oui donc c'est toujours par rapport à
l'offre politique que vous incarnez et
le problème pour jean michel bancaire
c'est peut-être at-il sous-estimé les
risques d'un liées à l'image d' emmanuel
macron enfin dont on m'a parlé avec ap
nicolas domenach et peut-être son propre
positionnement politique celle que jean
michel blanquer refasse à l'éducation
nationale il paie probablement pas juste
des épisodes en question pas juste la
gestion maladroite de la pandémie il
peut aussi une ligne politique parce que
il s'est dressé contre toute une partie
de l'état profond en quelque sorte de
l'éducation nationale il s'est dressé
contre le pédagogisme il s'est dressé
comme les tentations de d'accommodement
avec la laïcité je pense que ce qu'on
lui fait payer aujourd'hui c'est ça
aussi alors après comme n'est pas
forcément très très politique ils
sous-estiment probablement les avis que
kylie a contourné sur une posture
clivante justement à tendre le bâton
pour se faire battre sur des sujets
faciles alors effectivement ça ça ouvre
une partie de notre débat un chapitre
sur le bilan de jean michel blanc car
depuis deux ans dans la gestion de cette
crise sanitaire et je vous propose de de
le lire de lire pour commencer le
ministre de l'éducation nationale
c'était il ya il ya quelques minutes sur
réseau social aux média social twitter
depuis deux ans deux ans je travaille 7
jours sur 7 pour la gestion scolaire de
la crise sanitaire grâce au travail de
tous notamment des professeurs la france
a été le pays de l'école ouverte j'ai
pris cinq jours de congés
en lien chaque jour avec mon ministère
au service de l'école voilà ce que dit
jean michel blanquer tout à l'heure sur
sur twitter françois patriat c'est vrai
que l'école ouverte c'est quand même une
spécificité ou en tout cas une réussite
française ces deux si on fait le bilan
de ces deux années si on se compare aux
pays voisins je pense à l'italie à
d'autres on ouvrait bien que le fait
d'avoir maintenu l'école ça a été un pas
social en avant parce que les premières
victimes ont été les enfants donc
vouloir maintenir le matière ouverte
était à la fois courageux difficile ça
combien de mobiliser tout le monde le
monde enseignant qui je rends hommage en
l'occurrence mais aussi l'ensemble de
l'appareil de production à côté qu'il a
fait et les parents les parents qui sont
associés alors c'est vrai que vouloir
les maintenir à tout prix vote quel
telle alternative
pécresse a dit fermé bon moi j'aurais
voulu connaître la règle semaine
j'ai des petits-enfants
chez les enfants si on leur avait dit la
veille de la rentrée l'école est fermée
qu'est ce que je fais des enfants
à l'amont des vacances
beaucoup de médecins de virologues
épidémiologistes qui qui qui proposait
la même opté pour cette fille là qu'il
avait dit donc moi je pense que le choix
de l'école ouverte c'est un choix qui
honore la france et qui honore son
gouvernement oui mais est-ce que
finalement ça n'a pas été une erreur
politique là parce que le bilan de
toutes façons sur le louvre l'école
ouverte il était là et une semaine de
plus ou moins n'aurait pas changé grand
chose mais ce que je veux 4 % des écoles
enfermés quatre pour cent des écoles ont
fermé voilà ce qu'il fallait dans la
semaine 4 % fin pour avoir des enfants
en âge scolaire je peux vous garantir
que la scolarité depuis l'automne elle
est totalement chaotique et ça n'a rien
à voir avec les efforts des enseignants
on sait simplement il ya les cas
positifs tous les jours ont passé votre
vie à faire des tests et en des classes
ont fermé son père mais je vous assure
ça n'est pas la responsabilité de ce
plan car c'est la ville vous oubliez en
plus un facteur qu'il n'a pas été cité
c'est toutes les violences
intrafamiliales que le non ait causé par
antoine et qui ont explosé pour pas
l'oubli ça c'est aussi un film à lens
contre les environs tu es idiot c'est
une réussite française qui compte et ça
j'en
ai compté jean michel blanquer redis
j'ai pris quatre jours de vacances mais
vous avez raison les français maintenant
ne supporte plus rien de la part des
élus ils veulent des élus qui soit ont
dû avec une robe de bure une corde
autour du ventre en et pied et qui
marche doucement bel âge sont pas les
fall est pas ça qui se sont excusés mais
ce sont plutôt les oppositions
pardon pour l'utiliser parce qu'ils
savent qu'il ya une résonance de
l'opinion publique il utilise parce
qu'ils savent que c'est ça aujourd'hui
je crois qu'il fallait pour une autre il
va aller sonder les français
en même temps voilà c'est le jeu on est
dans une campagne électorale dans une
campagne électorale la moindre faute de
carre par n'importe quel acteur est
utilisé par les autres c'est le jeu de
la campagne électorale ça veut dire que
les ministres et les acteurs politiques
doivent redoubler ou triplé de alors
justement nicolas domenach je viens vers
vous là dessus parce que ça a été une de
mes réflexions depuis ce matin autour de
de cette polémique c'est décidément pas
facile de d'être élu et d'être et d'être
ministre aujourd'hui
en particulier du ministre de
l'éducation parce que françois patriat a
raison de le rappeler quand même ça a
été un sacré combat et combat alors les
enseignants étaient formidables mais je
vous rappellerai que les syndicats
d'enseignants du moins certains d'entre
eux certains certains épidémiologistes
ans ferme east je veux dire on ont cessé
de dire que le ministre de l'éducation à
les tuer les enfants que c'était un
scandale qu'on joue à la roulette russe
avec la santé de nos nos petits vire ça
a été une pression psychologique alors
qu'il ait pris quatre jours de vacances
par rapport à ça
il aurait pu en prendre plus un millier
de mai certaine façon parce que
qu'est-ce qui la caisse qu'il a pris
quand même là dessus j'ai quand même un
univers qui est très très dur alors qu'
il fallait pouvoir résister bas il a
tenu alors là tu maintenant qu'on lui
tombe dessus comme la vérole sur le bas
clergé je trouve que c'est un peu fort
quoi
c'est fini on est quand même dans une
image un peu d'epinal en jeu j'ai
l'impression qu'on joue un peu au naïf
autour de cette table parce que qui a
pris ses décisions et qui a tenu ce
emmanuel macron mais celui qui applique
la politique c'est oui d'accord jean
michel blanquer mais c'était manuel
macron qui décide de garder les écoles
ouvertes c'est emmanuel macron qui
décide de laisser son ministre partira
ibisa juste dans fait cette polémique
part parce qu'il n'est pas rentré à
temps pour encore une fois je reviens ce
que j'ai dit au début mais il serait
entré un temps pour l'interview du
parisien il n'y avait pas de polémique
donc je pense autrement dit des
interviews plus tôt alors été publié en
même temps que symbolise les rangs dans
le jdd il aurait pas eu de polémique
monclin
de koné la communication
dans la cuisine médiatique mais c'est
vrai que la photo qui lui viennent
interview jean michel blanquer forcément
c'est pas
décidé à son bureau bref oui mais je
pense que l'attitude des dirigeants
d'établissements qui avait appliqué le
protocole le lendemain elle était pas
tellement dié sur le lieu d'en parler
ministre à pinas je pense que cette
crise parce que regarder dans un débat
un peu hors seul parce que oui je
considère que c'est une grande réussite
et que jean michel blanquer a
incontestablement un très bon bilan de
ce point de vue là ça n'empêche pas
qu'il a été dans une espèce de postures
parfois de dénis épidémiologique déjà
des gens qui ont pu être contaminées à
cause des écoles des données elles se
disent assez largement devant nous mais
pourquoi je vous dis ça c'est pas il
fallait prendre une décision de toute
façon à la politique c'est d'arbitré n'y
avait pas de choix idéal en revanche
nous sommes dans une crise de la données
publiques en revanche il n'y a pas eu
suffisamment de contrôles c'est à dire
qu' il n'y a aucune étude d'impact nous
ne pouvons pas nous prononcer
aujourd'hui sur la fermeture des écoles
pour savoir si elle a été qu'à l'impact
épidémique salut ou même pour le mesurer
par rapport à d'autres enjeux les
violences intrafamiliales que vous aviez
raison de souligner parce que nous ne
faisons pas un travail sérieux sur la
collecte des données nous n'avons pas de
bilan sur les consignes mans nous
n'avons pas de bilan sur les couvre feu
nous n'avons pas de bilan enfin
sanitaire j'entends jure l'impact des
fermetures de commerces connaissance ya
donc forcément on en arrive à des débats
qui sont pour le coup épidermique parce
que tout simplement on les fait dans le
vide au début de la crise on peut avoir
des bilans philosophique sur faut-il
fermer et ouvrir aux privilégiés
l'économie ou la santé à tout prix on
peut avoir ces débats là quand on en est
à deux ans de pandémie nous devrions
avoir des débats sur des données
précises que nous n'avons pas manque de
transparence pas assez de données sql
d'accord je voudrais rebondir je ne peux
qu'approuver vraiment chasse il ya
vraiment un point qui est faible faire
notre vie politique d'un autre vie
institutionnelle c'est la question de
l'évaluation et des études d'impact en
écoutant la campagne présidentielle qui
est en train de se dérouler où on égrène
tous les jours des propositions dont
aucune ne fait l'objet de deux
dispositifs d'évaluation de dire on va
tester on va expérimenter on va voir si
ça marche qu'est-ce qu'on fait
signalement si ça ne marche pas et c'est
rude mais comment vous l'expliquez c'est
quoi c'est une façon de d'infantiliser
l'opinion qu'ont expliqué de deux
économistes il ya quelques années ont
publié un livre savant qui s'appelle le
négationnisme économique dans lequel il
ne cesse de se lamenter en disant c'est
vrai qu'en france on a une sorte de
perception des propositions politiques
qui est qu'elle doit changer le monde et
puis on renvoie à demain après demain
après après demain l'évaluation de cette
idée changé ni le débat sur le page sur
ce traitement de la même manière c'est
pour doigt mouillé selon l'idée qu'on
s'en fait cela voudrait dire plus d'
enquêtes d'opinion n'ont plus de travail
du parlement peut-être son visage c'est
le parlement qui doit contrôler value
c'est à dire d'avoir les dents
l'évaluation des politiques publiques on
le demande souvent pour les lois ils ont
les mêmes logiques que si les
parlementaires le demandent une forme
d'opacité d'anciens patriat c'est un
travail qui est fait notamment au sénat
mais aussi à l'assemblée lol et
commission d'enquêté parlementaire cep
logique ils vont les sénateurs la donne
raison au sénat mais tout est dit on
demande plus de types d'impacts surtout
avant les lois d'ailleurs on ne sait pas
suffisamment du fait de l'impact a primé
de cette journée que ce que moi je peux
tirer à toute personne en tant que
responsable politique d'un petit échelon
moi je souhaite que la campagne
électorale elle s'engage pas dans ce
genre de débat dans ce genre de coups un
football un pour être pour être très
pollué qu'elle s'engage bilan vraiment
consommé dans moi je veux que sur les
domaines de la santé de l'éducation de
l'environnement de la sécurité à flat on
est vraiment un indice un débat parce
que tous ceux qui attendent aujourd'hui
son ancien candidat tous tous qui ont
été aux responsabilités et qu'on fasse
le bilan bilan contre bilan parce que tu
veux pas la comparaison si je compare
avec l'hôpital ce qu'a fait ce
gouvernement avec le ségur les 19
milliards les investissements le plan de
relance où je vais avec le premier
ministre toutes les semaines inauguré
hier l'hôpital l'hôpital et puis tu as
lu avec été déposés devant pendant que
de déposer les mots grande chose que je
peux vous dire que si on fait ça la
campagne elle aura du sens parce que les
gens rappelleront fait les autres ce que
nous avons fait nous et ce que nous
proposons pour demain bien ce que vous
dites françois patriat parce que
justement dans cette émission on essaye
je pense qu'on y arrive régulièrement de
de creuser notamment les propositions de
campagne et ce sera le thème du second
débat tout à l'heure puisque on va se
pencher sur l'état de nos services
publics on parlera notamment de l'école
de l'hôpital et de la justice mais quand
même moi sur cette affaire là et je
voudrais entendre nicolas domenach là
dessus il ya des leçons à mon avis bien
sûr sur cette polémique autour de 2 des
vacances de jean michel mans car il ya
peut-être quand même une leçon politique
à tirer sur l'affaiblissement de ce
ministre au fur et à mesure de l'avancée
de cette crise sanitaire enfin est-ce
que nicolas domenach vous vous dites je
sais pas mais moi je pense ça tient du 5
ans oui oui ça c'est vrai mais est ce
que finalement retenu c'est pas le signe
la décision ou peut-être désinvolture
dans la communication le signe d'un
ministre qui se sent dépossédée de toute
prise de décision sur ces affaires de
crise sanitaire depuis des mois nicolas
domenach je crois pas qu'il soit le
déposséder moi je ne lis pas la crise
qu'on envie ce jour ces jours ci la même
façon que vous je la vis au contraire
comme le le début d'une prise de
conscience de qu'on est dans une
bataille politique qui s'engage qui va
s'engager en attend évidemment le chef
de campagne c'est-à-dire emmanuel macron
mais cette fois ci il faut faire bas il
faut il faut se serrer les coudes veut
dire sinon sinon ils marchent vers la
défaite donc s'est longtemps cassé les
échos que j'en ai ressenti alors
d'autant plus qu' on est là tout à
l'heure vous disiez il faut il faut
avoir des instruments pour mesurer les
erreurs qui peuvent être commises dans
les décisions qui sont prises mais
depuis hier on était face là en
l'occurrence un ennemi inconnu subir le
virus et qui demandait une souplesse et
de réaction et des décisions prises en
fonction
parfois contre des habits de
scientifiques dire que là on était plus
dans la politique classique en certes on
n'a pas les instruments pour mesurer les
la justesse des politiques adoptées mais
il fallait faire preuve d'une rapidité
demain il faudra faire preuve encore
plus et moi j'ai le sentiment au
contraire que c'est un jour comme
aujourd'hui fait que on a basculé dans
un autre moment politique partir de
maintenant merci beaucoup merci nicolas
domenach merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat nicolas domenach je rappelle
le titre de votre livre macron pourquoi
tant de haine